Miss Elizabeth Taylor: Academy Award - winning actress and AIDS activist.
Elizabeth Taylor was a film starlet...
...whose screen life was often upstaged by her personal life.
Throughout her long career, she won three Oscars,...
...including a special one for her humanitarian work.
She was tortured by illness, failed romances and personal tragedy.
Her eight marriages and turbulent personal life were well - chronicled.
Taylor, who was born in London became a star at age 12,...
...with the release of her film "National Velvet".
She married and divorced at 18,...
...became a screen goddess at 19,...
...and a widow at 26.
Taylor appeared in more than 50 films.
Her performances in "Butterfield 8"...
...and "Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf" won her Academy Awards.
Her most famous marriages and divorces were to the same person, actor Richard Burton.
She had a number of long - time famous friendships as well.
Her close friendship with Michael Jackson came back into the limelight...
...after the pop singer's death in 2009.
She remained close with National Velvet co-star Mickey Rooney...
...and fellow actor Roddy McDowall.
She was very close with Rock Hudson, who died of AIDS.
In later years, she championed several causes including AIDS research.
It was her charity work that earned her the humanitarian Oscar in 1993.
In 2000, Queen Elizabeth named Taylor a Dame,...
..the female equivalent of a knight, for Taylor's charity work.
When she turned 50, Taylor reflected to a reporter,...
..."I don't entirely approve of some of the things I have done, or am, or have been".
She added, "But I'm me. God knows, I'm me".
Lauri Neff, The Associated Press.